oh no no no no i can't no
I can't i can't do this i'm a belly driver from
richmond what the hell am i doing here i can't i
i'm an amputee from romania who shouldn't be
here either but i've seen you drive and shoot
better than most men in my army and right now the
only thing that matters is stopping that monster
okay
Ineed that bow
holy
Welcome back everyone this is my new marvel shang
chi deleted scenes alternate ending video there
were actually a couple different versions of
the ending in a lot of deleted scenes with a
bunch of easter eggs so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos the hawkeye
episodes are gonna start next week i'll be
doing videos for all the episodes just like i
do for all the other marvel disney plus series
careful for spoilers if you have not seen the
shang chi movie yet but the first alternate ending
big deleted scene is razer fists giving katy a
pep talk during their big final battle against
the soul eaters and the dweller in darkness
after all hell breaks loose in the ta lo village
razorfist and most of wenwoo's men have largely
switched sides at this point and are fighting
with the ta lo villagers to defeat the soul eaters
and this scene that i put at the beginning of this
is happening after shang chi has beaten his father
wenwu and wenwu sacrificed himself to the dweller
in darkness to save him having his big darth
vader vs the emperor return of the jedi star
wars redemption scene and now the dweller in
darkness has begun sucking the soul energy from
the great protector dragon so when razer fist is
telling katy that she's gotta use the bow it's all
to set that big twist with her landing the dragon
scale arrow in the dweller and darkness to stun it
long enough for shang chi to use the ten rings
and go full dragon ball finishing move on and
katy even literally drops a dragon ball reference
to shang chi in the movie in the theatrical cut
after he comes back shang used the 10 rings to
like do this like crazy kamehameha fireball that
exploded the thing so if this pep talk scene
feels familiar it's because it's also meant
to be a big callback to the hawkeye scarlet witch
scene from avengers age of voltron where he gives
her the famous pep talk about how none of what's
happening makes sense all he has is a bone arrows
but he's gonna try and do everything he can to
help and if she walks out that door with them
she's officially an avenger but if you step
out that door you are an avenger so it was
all about inspiring scarlet wish to choose
to be a hero which she did re-watching the
shang chi version of that scene with katy and
razorfist i totally get why they cut the scene
it's not as good as the avengers age of ultron pep
talk scene and it kind of slows the momentum of
this final battle down a lot it just goes on for
way too long and also in this version of the movie
they killed off razer fists during this fight
scene and it sounds like they wanted to bring
him back in the future 10 ring spin-off project
that marvel's working on right now because he
shows up during the actual post-credit scene where
he's serving shang chi's sister xia ling she's
taken over the 10 rings rebranded it a little with
her own styling like the same graffiti that was
all over the underground fight ring in macau
let's get started we have a lot of work to do
she's reorganized them so that they're more of a
shady business enterprise like she was running in
macau with a really strong mercenary army at her
disposal like there's slightly less evil than they
were under wenwoo she's probably not going to
be toppling governments anytime soon like what
they're trying to say in the post-credits scene
is that what's going on with xia ling in the ten
rings in the future of the mcu is very similar to
what's going on with sharon carter as the power
broker not evil but not exactly good characters
either and if you didn't hear the news marvel is
developing a 10 rings disney plus series spin-off
i don't know when that's going to be released
maybe 2023 or 2024 probably before shang chi 2
hits theaters but that's the whole reason that
the stinger message at the end says the 10 rings
will return instead of it saying shang chi will
return marvel said they did it that way for the
shi movie because they felt like everybody saw the
mid-credit scene and they'd assumed that they'd
be bringing shang chi back so they wanted to use
the message at the end to also remind people hey
the 10 rings are still very much a big deal in
the future of the mcu just because wenwu died
doesn't mean it's the last time you'll see this
organization the second alternate ending like the
next big deleted scene is actually with shang chi
and wen wu originally they were going to have wen
wu survive the final attack against the dweller in
darkness he was still going to give shang chi
the ten rings like he did when he sacrificed
himself but in the alternate version after they
defeat the dweller in darkness and he goes full
dragon ball on it wen wu would have still been
alive xia ling his sister was still going to take
over the 10 rings in the post-credits scene like
she did in the theatrical cut but if you're a big
tony lung fan as you all should be he said that
there was still a lot more wenwoo mandarin story
to tell like they had plans for a lot more of his
story in the mcu he didn't say exactly how they
planned to handle that but even though they killed
him in the movie they can still bring him back
it's just that now it has to be in flashbacks and
prequels for everybody that wants that mandarin
prequel series my first assumption is that we'd
see some flashbacks with him during shang chi 2
when we learn more about the true history of
the 10 rings themselves in the cosmic sense
like that's what part of the mid-credit scene was
for teasing the larger mystery about where the 10
rings came from what they were created for who
created them where the signal is broadcasting to
i've already done several videos about that so
i'll add links for those at the end of this and in
the description below because some of that's also
meant to be an avengers 5 teaser but shang chi
2 the sequel movie will just give us more
cosmic 10 rings backstory they can also
bring wenwu back for the 10 rings disney plus
series in flashbacks for xia ling storyline
but if he does come back mostly i'm just expecting
it to be in the movies in the disney plus series
that are based on the core shang chi characters
like shang chi and his sister xia ling like i'm
not expecting to see wen wu show up in a flashback
during spider-man 4 or anything like that the last
big deleted scene the last alternate ending that
i know about right now that they've released is
with xia ling and katy and it's actually an
alternate version of the post credit scene
it's the scene that happens right before she goes
and sits on the throne like she's in her room sort
of packing her things up talking to katy and in
the alternate version of the scene they just cover
more of she and katy 's relationship as a romantic
couple i wanted to cut your throat are you into
him too we have a really good friendship i don't
want to go and screw things up by complicating it
it's meant to be kind of a funny awkward scene
where xia ling gives katy the business like an
overprotective sister and grills her about whether
or not she's in love with shang chi for those of
you that were kind of wondering what the nature
of their relationship was like so in that scene
katy kind of implies there's some energy between
them like they could become a romantic couple at
some point but the way the director and the marvel
people said that they wanted to play their pairing
like they had a romantic subplot that was in the
movie that they kind of just got rid of like they
deleted a lot of other scenes that set that up
because the way they wanted to play their pairing
like the two of their characters together was in
more of a drawn out tony stark pepper potts kind
of scenario imagine if pepper potts had been
a bigger character in the first two iron man
movies like a bigger part of all the action scenes
in the fight scenes she really didn't get huge
fight scenes until iron man 3 when she got to wear
the armor for the first time and then at the end
of the movie when she got extremist powers briefly
imagine if tony and pepper had not gotten together
until the end of iron man 3 and they just taken
all their time developing their relationship
across the first three iron man movies in the
avengers movies so that's kind of what their
plans are for shang chi and katy together as a
couple but that's also why wang brings her to
the avengers meeting in kamar taj and says both of
their lives are about to change forever like she's
invited to this big avengers 5 party that they're
going to be throwing in a couple years surprise
it's the end of the world again we're all getting
together bring the ten rings and your friend katy
so you can kind of see the difference in how
they're trying to make her a bigger character
in chiang chi's story line as opposed to pepper
potts who is a big character but she wasn't really
around for a lot of the avengers teasers in the
iron man movies like in this post-credits scene
here is just nick fury and iron man but just in
terms of that sequel movie i don't think that
shang chi 2 will be released till at least 2023
or 2024 so that 10 rings disney plus series might
wind up being released before that so unless
they announced some other big crossover before
that that's probably where shang chi will show
up next during the 10 rings disney plus series
big reminder too the hawkeye episodes start
next week my hawkeye episode 1 and episode
2 video will post wednesday because they're
dropping the first two episodes on day one
make sure you have alerts enabled for my channel
so you don't miss any of that and i'll just keep
doing the disney plus giveaway for memberships
throughout all those hawkeye episode videos
congratulations to the giveaway winner from
my last big spider-man video bruce lee please
message me on the back end of my channel so i can
get your contact details everyone click here for
my full spiderman no way home trailer breakdown
easter eggs and that mystery andrew garfield scene
and click here to learn about the eternals
easter egg during the shang chi post-credits
scene thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!